an interesting thing happened in films
last year not many of us women were in
any but for those who were thrift shop
fashions were out and high fashions were
back in to illustrate the point the next
award will be presented by a star of
such elegance who has such style that
she makes blue jeans look like
Balenciaga and sweatshirts like Saint
Laurent the rest of us like bums and
does she know how to whistle my friend
Miss Lauren Bacall
Thank You Shirley movies are influencing
fashion again there was a time when
every woman wanted to dress like Garbo a
Lombard Clark Gable took her shirt off
when it happened one night and it took
18 years for Brando to bring the t-shirt
back most of the designs nominated this
year are based on yesterday and once
again are influencing the fashions of
today I like that because it proves that
romance is on its way are you ready for
it I am no knees for best achievement
and costume designer and fierce Silbert
for Chinatown
next nominee is John finesse for Daisy
Miller
and then again to the
turn-of-the-century
next theodora van Runkle for The
Godfather Part 2
now back to the thirties but look at the
most stunning group of passengers you
ever saw on a train I can say that now
because the votes are all in the next
nominee is my darling Tony warden for
Murder on the Orient Express
the only Aldrich for the Great Gatsby
look over twenties and here it is folks
nervous time the winner is the only the
Aldrich for the Great Gatsby
I would like to thank the members of the
Academy paramount mr. Hank moon gene
stirrer David married and a very special
man my director Jack Layton I love you
jack and I'm very very proud to have
been a part of your film thank you
ladies